all right we are here in sunny Los
Angeles and we're gonna be doing episode
on pork so we've done American barbecue
pork ribs before oh yeah today we're
doing pork Filipino style I am so
excited for Filipino food let's go
today I'm worth it we're gonna be trying
three Filipino pork dishes at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
at its price I have quite the number of
Filipino friends telling me make a worth
of episode we're on Filipino food okay
okay brag I have so many friends yeah oh
no I don't have that many friends I just
pretend like I do I only have two
friends and they're in this car that's a
good moment to introduce the fact that
we have four people in the car
Dani whoa so the first place we're going
to is called rice bar we're gonna eat
with a friend her name is Ali she's
Filipino she loves pork pork equals pig
is that correct
porky the pig that's right oh man and I
just got said I imagine eating 40 the
pig I'm Charles alia chef/owner of Bryce
bar here in downtown Los Angeles what
type of establishment is rice bar
everyday filipino affairs something that
you'd only find in homes you know like
the Holy Trinity of breakfast garlic
rice which is central to the Philippines
the egg and and along in ISA so the pork
longanisa it's essential Filipino
sausage Joanne we make is from my region
of a Bunga but we've added a little bit
of la flair to it already so it's a 7
ounce sausage more geared towards the
appetite of how we eat over here we
start off with fresh ground pork we
don't ground the fat we actually dice it
gives better texture to the sausage try
that for two days stuff it and natural
hog casing and let it cure again for
another three days the garlic the pepper
the sugar the salt can really penetrate
that meat and by the time we serve it to
the guests
the flavors are way more robust we cook
it slowly in the griddle until it
caramelizes so you have a beautiful
glaze and the sausage then we pair that
off for the garlic fried rice so we make
a very intense garlic oil like a 1 to 1
ratio of garlic to oil get our rice
toast it and coat raw then we put our
garlic stock and a little bit of a nod
to water to give it the yellow color you
have all the flavors to the very inside
of the grain so it's cooked in that
garlic stock yes and then we pair that
off with pickled papaya which rounds out
the whole dish well
I want that one hello hi hi this is Ali
so your Filipino long denisa is
something that I used to have growing up
usually at carnivals and fairs that kind
of thing or you would like have it for
breakfast so this brings you back yeah
are you guys eating Filipino style
before you have spoon in the right hand
before from the left hand and you shovel
the food onto the spoon do you want to
try it yeah together okay ready cheers
cheers Cheers
it's got that sweetness to it huh
there's so many things going on there
with the sausage good texture and then
it's a little spice and it's just like
everything's nice I love sausage sausage
might be my single favorite food why I
grew up eating a lot of sausage if you
think about what is going on into making
a sausage it's crazy but also genius
repackaging an animal into like a
delicious little flavor missile kind of
gross actually so this is the spicy
vinegar let's head that up
one of the major flavors of the
Philippines the sourness and so that
spicy vinegar goes well with everything
oh yeah oh yeah sweetness and the
sausage with the spicy vinegar that's it
right there
so this is like a perfect Filipino
breakfast egg rice some kind of meat
product I could get obsessed with the
garlic rice like that alone I would
travel far and wide poor it's really
good to have something like this in a
restaurant because our you know growing
up I only had it at home I can like take
my friends here who have never had this
before are you ready this is gonna be a
big bite whoa what do you think I'm just
whispered it's really good the quieter
he says it the more he means it the
other addition we're gonna have is our
house-made spam casino to see you know
in the Philippines is kind of like our
bacon again diced fat high in sugar very
simple we cook him in the spam can in a
water bath let that rest for about three
days and then slice it off brulee it
with a little bit of sugar so you get
the nice caramelization we're gonna pair
that off with black rice an heirloom
variety from the side of the Philippines
very high in anthocyanins just like with
blueberries and spinach some pickled
radishes and some you choice okay that
is beautiful
you know got color textures god there's
nothing I love more than the spam as a
kid
cheers Cheers hot damn mm-hmm oh damn
it's so good the rice is life seriously
blowing me away why does it almost taste
Ocoee to me very delicious and with all
these other ingredients in there look at
that it looks like your vegetable garden
I've always been good grow from the
ground bees thank you so much for
joining us and you're very welcoming you
who are having us
I think family-style is pretty much the
only way to eat heavier Filipino because
so much of the food is about community
and about family we even say that we're
a family you and I I mean the three of
us yeah we're something
rice bar what a treat before we go into
our port fact we're gonna be hitting up
jollity for a quick hallo hallo break oh
look there's the B we've got a big bosom
do you know what bosom is isn't it your
butt no it's a woman's chest area I did
not know that wild I like this whole
cake on top pork back only about 30% of
pork is consumed fresh the breast is
cured or smoked and eaten as bacon ham
in sausage bacon ham sausage that's a
pretty strong team of foods right there
they should be holding the ball playing
the game holding the pigskin boom next
up window place got lhasa it's a big cut
pork belly I've been told that I don't
have the voice on the radio person
person
[Music]
I'm chef Chad Valencia co-owner of Lhasa
we're a seasonal Filipino inspired
restaurant here in Chinatown la from my
understanding Lhasa a Tagalog is flavor
flavor or taste can you talk about what
that means for you guys it's based on
our life experiences so this is not
traditional Filipino food by any means
my brother and I come from California
restaurants so we follow the seasons
what's hopping at the market is gonna
dictate what ingredients are gonna get
used looking what can coincide with
Filipino dishes but isn't that specific
ingredient for instance in springtime
there's a sour soup called sinigang we
use rhubarb to sour the broth that's not
traditional by any means but if any
Filipino were to taste that broth they
would know it's Inigo and you're using
rhubarb because that's what you have
here in California
exactly we're gonna eat our twice-cooked
pork belly it's based on a Filipino dish
called cala bassa
onion at the on which means squash
student coconut there's always the
addition of pork product and shrimp
product and a lot of vegetable dishes in
the philippines so we flipped it on its
head and turned it into an entree we
take skin on onliest for belly slabs and
slowly render on a plancha so that the
skin and ZEB crispy we do the kabocha
squash in coconut milk until it's
extremely tender then we puree it then
we walk roast Chinese long beans and
then we take mustard greens and we dress
that in bugling vinegar so we have this
fresh salad to kind of cut through the
richness of the belly and then that even
the kabocha and coconut people are
always quick to say oh you guys are
doing Filipino fusion Filipino food is
already fusion by a way of China Spain
America we're not doing anything that
different we're just doing California
Filipino food that's right yeah I'm
ready to eat green mango soda
Cheers whoo gentle bubbles sodas are
better when the bubbles are gentle
agreed let's eat I'm gonna do a little
puree taste-test solo mode before I get
into this all right Cheers
whoa someone's like pumpkin pie at first
I was like okay it's a squash and then
there's this whole other flavors that
run across your mouth okay so here we
got a thick cut pork belly it's like a
steak of pork when I do a little squash
yes I'm going along beans too
Cheers
the hard exterior of this pork belly
very satisfying hmm no crunch how fun is
that it's all about into the the bellies
of things you know
yeah the Beast of the rock the rock yeah
you know the rock like his ads oh yeah
sure yeah he's got a nice belly we share
a lot of dishes on this show uh-huh
and we're often times like huddled over
one small plate like nibbling away this
was created to be shared that's right
big big cut pork belly right in the
middle on a huge plate hey come over
here
damn win the style yeah you want to
double down double down oh that's lovely
hold out your hand and I'm gonna fly the
camera into it we're cool wha twist
we're in New York City
we're here because this is a very
special dish that we're gonna try in
fact it's not even a dish it is a feast
but before we get there I know it's
happening
oh we all know what's happening it's no
longer happening Oh hundreds of years
ago all pork was referred to as bacon or
as it was spelled back then baked gun
the be a cou a yeah you have to spell if
it comes from the old Teutonic
background that refer to the back of the
hog bacon back on how's that for a fact
borderline factual pretty good it's
pretty good pretty good thank you thank
you very much
we'll go in a restaurant and call
jeepney good they sort of what's called
a combined feast in the middle of it
we're gonna have a whole pig stuff
[Music]
name's Nicole Fonseca and we're cheap me
here in the East Village
you're gonna eat nueva york style latch
on and we're also gonna do a combined
feasts what is Kamiya
combined is basically to eat with your
hands
we lay out all the food on banana leaves
very beautifully because we know with
that we eat with our eyes first but it
wasn't really like that for me growing
up combined was just my dad in the
kitchen eating and a play just with
their hands like really simple really
humble my whole mission is
how can I help spread Filipino food but
also how can I take anything that I was
ever embarrassed or ashamed about and
make it into something that I'm really
proud about so we decided to do it this
beautiful way of introducing Filipino
food and culture chef Miguel is going to
tell you about the dishes that we're
having today for this particular combine
we created a special feast for you guys
we have some dinner ghoul ones and
banana rich Zampa fried which is our
marinated whole red snapper let's not
forget about the chicken adobo
considered the national dish of the
Philippines then you have the star of
the show our whole little what is LeSean
can you kind of walk that into that let
some is a whole pig traditionally we
would be roasting it over an open fire
pit we are in the East Village we would
probably get our asses busted for doing
something like that so we cook our
lachung in the oven we're gonna stuff it
with lemongrass onions salt pepper and a
shitload of love and lunga nisa bring
that temperature up to 500 just to crisp
that skin and sear everything so we want
to trap all those juices in there and
then we lower that temperature and let
it grow slowly so like that when you
guys get it and you crack open that skin
that meat is just falling off the bone
the pig did you guys will be having
today is about 22 pounds so you guys
better be hungry
we are extremely hungry also we're
bringing in backup what 10 friends you
think that's enough people I think 10
friends is a good number
thank you all to our friends for joining
us today I just want to raise a toast to
all y'all for coming out cheers guys oh
we have some hot towels coming
okay a common phrase we used for cheers
of saga the8
[Applause]
[Music]
ready hey with my hands
I'm gonna teach you all how to do
combine if you make a little rice ball
you've been here in the front fingers
and then you push it into your mouth
with your thumb yeah oh my like this all
the time but I would refuse because
there was a bratty little kid but now I
wish I had paid attention because I
don't know what I'm doing as it is
sausage do you want to cut into the
Letran is that cool
sorry gosh my ball I want to hit us at
Andrew he's usually the one hand on that
look at that this game popping out
there's sausages in there
[Music]
why is it so important that eating with
your hands aspect it's a way of
respecting what you're eating and also
interacting with other people at the
table to catch up on what's going on in
your life you know this very intimate
moment and vulnerable moment of eating
with your hands I believe Brenda wanted
some ear they will click taste that
they're not as strong oh that's more
than just ear it's like a fortune cookie
[Music]
the cartilage is almost like glass it's
like rock candy it's so intense if
you're eating the wisdom of the universe
right now you would never know the kind
of gossip this big there's a lot
happening on this table yeah do you
think that there is a single bite that
you personally find the most delicious
yeah for me I'm gonna go straight for
the cheek on that pig oh man it's so
fatty
[Music]
y'all I gotta bet we're plating your
like melted butter that's what the cheek
meat is insane
[Music]
second is a double deal ow first we take
the chicken and we poach it for about
three minutes just to tighten that skin
so when we pan sear it that skin isn't
falling apart or breaking we put it in
the pot with garlic and bay leaf vinegar
soy and tumeric and let that cook until
it's nice and tender take that later and
we're gonna finish it off by putting it
under the salamander getting that skin
nice and crispy and we'll finish it off
with the sauce okay so I think everybody
should try the adobo the national dish
of the Philippines chicken tears good
[Music]
oh my god the parade of meats is insane
in this dinner so the other hidden gem
of this meal is the dinner one it's a
pork blood stew one of my favorite
dishes we take pork butt which we
marinate and salt pepper garlic and
vinegar it's gonna permeate through the
meat and it's gonna make it more
flavorful we let it sit overnight sear
it off in a cast-iron place that in our
braising pan take some aromatics onions
and garlic along with pork broth cook it
until it's nice and soft and then we'll
be adding the blood once it comes out it
thickens becomes as rich chocolate color
and that's ready for serving it's right
in front of you if you see it right here
it's Bloods do cheers guys it's very
rich it's almost like minerally so even
though it's like really rich and the
minerality kind of that's it a little
bit it's breezy the range of work
flavors that you get here sweet
longanisa
and the really fatty lechon so you also
have this really deep stew I just want
to say thank you everybody for joining
us for this awesome meal is there
anything else that you want to say it
has the Filipino food baton on Teddy not
just let's eat let's eat cheers guys
good night
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah pretty good right that's good cool
this is hard but I'm gonna ask you and I
expecting the answer because that's what
we do on this show which Filipino pork
dish wasn't much worth it to you at its
price every place was the perfect thing
in its category lots that would be my
perfect date night meal rice bar is the
ultimate fill you up good snack and
jeepney is just the perfect celebration
meal choosing between them is just like
I can tell you about what kind of day
you're gonna okay
rice bar oh I love that restaurant
feeling that you could be family with
strangers there oh it's so hard but
that's yeah yeah yep yeah your turn
I think jeepney slightly edges it out
for me the format of the meal is so fun
that you're guaranteed a memorable meal
so me about eating with your hands
shoulder shoulder with people this is
hard this hurts lhasa no ways through
his wit I think I have a crush on
Filipino cuisine it's stuck in my mind
sweet meat with a vinegar touch like I
just want more you wake up thinking
about it you go to sleep taste in it in
your belches oh yes